whatever is going on in the Skies over
of Montana I'm talking about the
discovery of a giant balloon visible
from the ground that has quickly turned
into a national security concern tied to
China that's because Pentagon officials
say they are convinced that this thing
on your screen is part of a Chinese spy
operation China for its part neither
confirming or denying saying they're
going to look into it this is happening
by the way the timing is interesting
just before Secretary of State Anthony
blinken plans to visit Beijing senior
investigative correspondent Catherine
Herridge is in Washington for us
Catherine good morning Good morning Tony
this balloon was spotted over Montana
this week and the Pentagon has been
tracking it floating at 66 000 feet
above the U.S in Canada for a couple of
days now there are nuclear missile silos
in Montana and while there's been a
bipartisan outcry to counter any threat
from this balloon officials say for now
they plan to let it be
but what the heck is that as the Silvery
orb hovered over Montana air traffic
temporarily shut down and fighter jets
scrambled
some special air Mission material we
know according to a senior defense
official the suspected Chinese spy
balloon was spotted over Billings
Montana on Wednesday it flew from
Alaska's Aleutian Islands through Canada
and into Montana
defense secretary Austin traveling in
the Philippines Wednesday convened
senior defense leadership secretary
Galvez
uh thanks for a very productive meeting
the chairman of the Joint Chiefs
recommended against military action and
the Pentagon decided against shooting
down the balloon because of the danger
posed by Falling debris balloon is
currently traveling at an altitude well
above commercial air traffic and does
not present a military or physical
threat if it were a threat I have every
confidence that we would have already
dealt with it by now former senior
intelligence official Dale Meyer Rose
sent the Chinese have launched similar
operations before so was this an
intelligence gathering operation it's
more intelligence about how we think how
we react rather than picking up
locations or activity on the ground the
Spy balloon Discovery comes just ahead
of next week's meeting between U.S
Secretary of State Anthony blinken and
China's president I find the timing
interesting or I can't help but think
that this was a deliberate action on our
part and we believe that that it
provides us with some sort of talking
point leverage or or Advantage either in
the ongoing talks or the ones that are
upcoming
my rose told us these things happen
often but they are rarely confirmed by
the U.S government this morning Chinese
officials called the claims of a spy
balloon hype until the facts are clear
Tony
all right so Catherine they're not
shooting it down as of yet what might
they do going forward
well a short time ago Tony a U.S
official told CBS news that there are a
number of options they could try and jam
the signals that it's sending back to
the Chinese military and intelligence
services or they could take a wait and
see when it gets to an area where it
might be possible to shoot it down and
to make a decision at that point
all right we'll keep following it
Catherine thank you very much you're
welcome